we're flying in a guest newsie right
into the desk
and she is a co-anchor at our affiliate
station fox 5 san diego please welcome a
woman who i personally invited here we
did it she showed up we made it happen
shelly zamarrok
oh i put too much a on your name zomeron
no it's beautiful it's perfect i cannot
believe i'm sitting here next to you i'm
so glad we're here together i am so
happy before we get started on the news
when last time i talked to you you said
i said can i bring you something from
san diego i said sand
outside and that's not all you brought
here
that's not all no you also brought your
friends and family who are here in the
audience supporting you
we don't we don't travel alone
[Laughter]
i'm so excited to have a piece of your
home heart right here thank you
so much you're welcome well we are
newsies we are we do the news that's
what i've been doing for many many many
many many many years i've been on your
show many many many many times we are
finally here together shall we hit some
headlines let's do it charlie let's do
that all right
all right charlie up first we've got a
boston couple who you know didn't let a
little thing like a blizzard ruin their
wedding insider reports sally and adam
arujo were supposed to get married at
the public library in providence rhode
island when a humungo snowstorm hit so
they were holed up at the hilton with
like 40 of their guests and you know
what they decided to do
get married anyway
yes they did
the wedding party walked to the storm
straight to the library's steps and the
couple was married by adam's dad and
after the kiss adam made it official by
pelting his wife with a snowball
romantic
uh don't you love this i think they said
mother nature try it try it it's not
gonna happen can't stop love thank you
so much cannot stop love and pelting a
snowball is one way to start a marriage
i think this is again why this is so
meaningful to me is its memories how
much more memorable is this wedding now
because of the visuals the
the sensorial i'm this is incredible
it's like a commercial yeah and so much
of weddings nowadays becomes so much
about the party and inviting all the
guests but let's be real that's marriage
and you don't know what's gonna happen
every day and you just roll with it so
if you can start your marriage like that
your money is it true that you're a
vowel renewer oh
you are i believe she's charlie
greetings yes you've officiated why i
officiate weddings now and so you are
that this is i mean that's a what what
prompted uh followers and viewers they
started messaging me and say i need you
to i'm a big fan of love and people know
that on social yeah so they started
messaging me and saying would you marry
us and i'm like i'm just the news lady
what do you
and they would not take no for an answer
and the letters just kept coming and
coming so i got licensed and now i
officiate weddings i
love this so much i'm such a romance
love junkie i just i love it and i love
that you did that yes being with people
on the happiest day of their lives
there's something so powerful about that
that my my husband sometimes is like
honey we gotta be the kids we gotta do
this and you're gonna do another wedding
and i'm like but honey it's love it's
love shall we we should do a wedding
here on the show
[Applause]
you know me you know we're gonna make
this happen yes i know you it will
happen all right well
okay i think we have a lot on the menu
and uh yeah there's still more headlines
here at charlotte okay here i'm so i'm
from california and we spend a lot of
time in our cars and there's some
upsetting news i don't like to do
upsetting news but i'm going to do it
today car scoops reports that a new
scientific study found that your car
is dirtier than a toilet
the research was conducted by aston
university school of biosciences and in
every single vehicle they tested
i have to say this out loud they found
fecal bacteria
and they found it all over the place
all over the place with the highest
bacteria readings and the trunk
why in the trunk
but then it's in the driver's seat
it may make you think twice the next
time that you uh get that in and out
food and you're eating and
it makes sense of course we're pulling
all this stuff and have you have we
looked at our behavior the i mean and my
kids my car oh my god it's it's insane
how how filthy my car is with the
wrappers and the drive-through and the
boots and the slices of pizza i mean
listen hands up who has a messy vehicle
[Laughter]
um
all right
obviously i'm saying this from this desk
[Laughter]
who here is completely clean and and
free of fecal matter in your car
really yeah these scientists did not
check my car i'm telling you right now i
can guarantee it all right charlie you
have kids
what's your car like i have kids i have
four kids there's like ketchup stuck on
the ground gum stuck somewhere where
it's a mess it's a mess because i have
to wash my card literature every two
hours to keep it clean you know actually
here's what i do now what i keep a roll
of garbage bags
oh i do oh and i say that's it
everybody either nice little white
garbage bags and i whip it out and i say
everybody we are not getting out of this
car if there is one thing that's not in
the garbage bag
i love that okay
i grew i looked i changed take a roll of
little garbage bags in your vehicle
and as far as the trunk and the shoes
and the life and everything just you
know get some wipes and do your best
[Music]